Marvel has already told us who's gonna
die at the end of Guardians the Galaxy
3. all you need to do is look at the
logos the logo for Guardian one has a
hard dark brown exterior with a softer
lighter brown interior you know what
else is brown on the outside and light
brown on the inside Groot a hard outer
Brown Bark with light brown wood in the
middle remind me again who died at the
end of Guardians one oh yeah it was
Groot now look at the logo for volume 2.
it's blue and red just like another new
member of the Guardians team in this
movie yandu blue skin Redfin and who
died in that one yondu what does this
tell us about volume 3 well there are
actually two logos the original one was
gray and textured just like Drax with
his gray skin and Tattoos the other is
lighter brown with black letters just
like rockets brown fur and black stripes
Dave Batista has said on record that he
is done playing Drax meanwhile the
villain of this new movie is the high
evolutionary the dude who outright made
rocket sorry to be the bearer of bad
news but Drax and Rocket are totally
gonna bite it at the end of this new
movie because